[Musique]
lorenza malaise baronnet bonjour bonjour
merci d'être sur le plateau de tv
soixante dix huit pour ce vip qui vous
est entièrement consacré vous êtes ici
parce que vous êtes la présidente d'une
organisation une ong qui s'appelle
soroptimist fait à vous être la
présidente du groupe de versailles voilà
j'ai l'impression vous êtes un peu
italienne complètement même un italien
et donc vous êtes là pardon je vous donc
vous êtes là en tant que présidente de
cette ong et vous êtes là parce qu'il ya
un événement qui te prépares très
important qui va avoir lieu le 16 mars
ça s'appelle talents de femmes et on va
y revenir un petit peu plus tard voilà
déjà moi j'aimerais qu'on fasse déjà
plus mieux connaissance avec vous
lorenza avec allah donc vous êtes
italienne vous êtes de quelle région
était alors je suis de la région du
piémont nord de l'italie plutôt vers les
ligues majeures l'alberta donc très
jeune la très belle région
je voyais à dire le contraire mais tout
et vous l'aï dit moi alors qu'est ce qui
vous a fait venir en france c'est quoi
votre parcours alors mon parcours c'est
pendant
la femme de mon bac et que je devais
rentrer à l'université j'ai décidé de
faire mon stage est de venir en france
pour apprendre le français déjà déjà
voilà je parlais pas français du tout
donc je suis arrivé à 91 le 7 juillet et
à partir des couleurs à quelle heure
passe était 20h30 et d'ailleurs
forcément on était venu me chercher à la
report et qu'un jeu vu paris pour la
première fois j'ai eu vraiment beaucoup
de coeur et je suis tombé amoureux il
ait away
c'était vraiment exceptionnel so culture
s'est dit là et tout qu'est ce qui
représente à pour la suite j'ai décidé
de rester lit donc j'ai appris le
français j'ai travaillé au début de ma
carrière pour une entreprise que c'était
plutôt sur la décoration à un niveau et
italiens pour le marché français et
quand j'ai décidé de rentrer en italie
bas j'ai rencontré mon mari est français
eh oui donc vous n'êtes pas entré en
italie non je ne suis pas rentré chez
moi j'ai eu cette rencontre était il m'a
il m'a donné envie de rester et dé bâtir
ma vie familiale ici avec lui avait
françois cau way et du coup là vous
travaillez dans quel domaine et donc et
pour la suite après mon mariage
j'avais pris une année sabbatique pour
préparer mon mariage et après à travers
des connaissances aussi de mon mari je
suis tombé sur mon métier qui est
pratiquement à ça mais c'était étonnant
on va dire ça comme ça je suis un truc
dans une société d'ingénierie
informatique des sociétés des services
qu'est ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui des
scènes et à la suite d sahin 2002 j'ai
pris la décision de créer des fondé le
groupe aux médiums qui est pour la suite
on m'a rejoint deux associés guillaume
eric et aujourd'hui on développe donc
cette entreprise d infrastructure
management et spécialisée surtout aussi
avec cap d'attaqué c'est une entreprise
de base des données d'accord donc on les
a utilisés dans les chefs d'entreprise
tout à fait voilà vous êtes chef
d'entreprise vous vous êtes aussi donc
comme on disait tout à l'heure président
de l'omg
optimiste pour le club de versailles
alors soroptimist tout le monde ne sait
pas ce que c'est ça a démarré cette ong
elle a débuté je crois en 1912 états
unis 1921 aux états et non mais il ya un
mais voilà au tout début c'était un
mouvement aux états unis et en france
c'est arrivé à
en 1924 d'accord et c'était sous un noël
que c'était une femme chirurgien qui
répare est qu'est ce qu'on appelait dans
le jir gaulle les gueules cassées de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
ok c'était une des premières femmes
médecins j'imagine tu as fait une
logistique complexe combler les manques
il a fait un travail exceptionnel
pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale et
donc ce mouvement aujourd'hui on a quand
même 76 mille membres dans le monde
entier
c'est donc d'ici essaimé dans le monde
entier finale maintenant c'est parti de
là qu'elle dise à vannes voilà et après
on la sent 23 pays
la tomate et lyrique des clubs des clubs
répartis en france si on peut dire on a
19 clubs
voilà onze dont versailles qu'est
versailles quand même depuis 1934 il ya
quand même mais plus de 82 ans de
résistance paris s'est plutôt plus de 50
bien entendu est donc dans les yvelines
ça fait quand même mais plus de 92 ans
donc oui c'est quand même mieux en 1
j'ai extrêmement importante
alors moi j'ai vu la définition de cette
ong enfin j'espère que c'est ça c'est
autour de l'entrepreneuriat
effectivement et vous dites c'est
comprendre alors la déviation de rendre
défendre les intérêts entreprendre alors
c'est un mouvement dont on a des femmes
qui sont engagés dans la vie
professionnelle
c'est une voix universelle justement qui
comporte même à l'onu à l'unesco dans
les conseils européenne
et ses excuses - et c'est une voie pour
justement donc autonomiser les
leadership de la femme c'est pour
défendre la touques esquissé contre la
violence des femmes s'est améliorée
aussi la vie des filles parce que c'est
à travers aussi legacy gêne dans la
vallée aujourd'hui nous on est en france
en europe et dans des pays qui intrigue
mais on est quand même favorisé
villégier mais privilégié mais dans
d'autres pays du monde et
malheureusement la reddition de la femme
mais elle est quand même problématique
et c'est toujours à travers l'éducation
et avec des projets communs parce qu'on
a quand même on a plus de 7 millions de
dollars dans l'année avec 4 44 mille
projets dans le monde d'un plié on porte
justement cette
cette voie pour la femme justement pas
d'accord donc là on a une photo qui
s'affichait sur notre écran
là c'est le jour de votre réseau vous
avez pris la présidence
tout à fait et alors il ya votre maman
qui sur la photo et parce que justement
votre maman déjà en italie faisait
partie des soroptimists exactement vous
avez toujours été baignée finalement là
dedans tout à fait parce qu'à un moment
c'est une vraie soroptimist à dire il ya
des fossés des vraiment non non non pas
du tout mais entre guillemets c'était
une des femmes qui est il a ouvert le
club artésien unis arrivera chez nous en
italie et donc j'ai toujours rayon maman
très engagé avec vraiment au sens des
valeurs et qui nous a élevés qu on a
baigné la lame dans l'exemple et donc
est à ce moment là quand je suis venu
habiter à versailles en 2001 et la
contacter la présidente de l'époque que
c'était madame marie nadeau prix etc et
d'ailleurs je fais une petite parenthèse
c'est ma marraine aux six mètres et que
c'était aussi la présidente nationale de
france et qui les représentent et aussi
à l'unesco
et oui et donc ils ont jumelé les clubs
des mamans avec un manant de prix là je
me laissais club et donc ma marraine la
date du prix et la dispo maintenant que
ta maman est là j'ai mené le club
on veut que tu intègres le club dé
versailles et donc ça fait 18 ans qui
est j'ai participé kg travail avec tous
ces familles sera ordinaire parce que
qu'on vous savez on club n'ait pas fait
simplement par la présidence mais s'est
fait par une communion des fins qu'ils
ont les mêmes valeurs le sens des
connexions la commune on n'est pas tout
seul on est vraiment ensemble à la force
et c'est la cohésion de ses femmes avec
exactement
alors justement vous organiser donc ça
c'était la photo de votre président a
fait une présidence vous organiser des
événements je crois oui et qui
permettent de récolter des fous
exactement pour dix jours 10 heures et à
d'autres associations qui intervient
dans le terrain et l'accord nous on
n'intervient pas sur le terrain vous
leur permettez d'agir avec la d'agir
avec l'arrière qui ont rassuré et
exaltante là par exemple
voix c'était le jour d'une projection
oui cinématographique un profond voilà
donc j'imagine que les spectateurs
l'argent du des spectateurs oui alors
c'est donc et chaque année le 25
novembre contre la violence des femmes
la france donc avec sa présidente
nationale choisi mon film et on le
transmet pendant dix jours contre la
violence de la femme dalle tout la
france des clubs
donc cette année c'était justement les
conquérantes les comores voilà les
cohérente donc qui je remercie aussi le
jeu c'est dé versailles pas ce qui nous
a permis gratuitement d'avoir la salle
et l'argent que lara culte et on l'a
donné à l'association arrive très bien à
l'association à versailles pour les
femmes à la rue et que ça ou ça c'est un
exemple précis
donc vous vous essayez d'avoir le
maximum d'actions comme sa tentation
pour récolter des fonds
je commence juste en deux trois mots
comment si on veut adhérer à ce
mouvement parce que vous me disiez tout
à l'heure vous êtes présidente depuis
bientôt trois ans 18 ans présidente non
trois ans des présidences deux ans et
demi des précédentes années 80
d'engagement d'engagement voilà donc
comment on fait si on veut vous
rejoindre il faut alors à rennais alors
maintenant on demande toujours à les
femmes de venir au moins pendant trois
dîners passé on se rassemble on fera par
mois pour voir un peu cheap la
motivation la motivation caioni qu'est
ce qu'on fait c'est à partir de là c'est
souhaité rentrer ballon rond de marennes
bien entendu et qu'on trouve sur place
ou qu'il faut connaître déjà parfois
maintenant ils peuvent les trouver sur
place on n'est pas obligé de d'abord non
pas du tout c'est vraiment mon
engagement personnel d'accord et c'est
pourquoi les âges c'est pour tous les
âges des toits vont être fameux chefs
d'entreprise n'ont pas chef d'entreprise
mais en femme engagée dans la vie
professionnelle
alors justement en parlant de travail et
y ait cet événement qui arrive le 16
mars
c'est à la mairie de versailles ça
s'appelle talents de femmes c'est le
premier salon à versailles alors qu'il
est il ya une cinquantaine de
participants tout à fait voilà quel est
le but du seul événement talent des
femmes c'est
dans toute la france tous les clubs et
organise de chaque année cet événement
pour mettre justement en avant
l'entrepreneuriat délamine à mannheim la
femme et peut avoir des talents sur tous
les niveaux c'est pas simplement sur le
côté artisanat et tout ça mais ça peut
être une femme aussi chef d'entreprise
ça peut être un avocat un architecte
tous les métiers confondus et on a eu la
chance cette année parce qu'on a des
pianos on a indiqu bouquet qui nous a
rejoints dans notre pleut et avec le
maire de versailles et nous a permis
d'accéder à d'avoir gratuitement
justement la salle de la mairie de
versailles pour créer cet événement
cet événement on le crée aussi avec
intérêt une marche etc etc avec les
bouge ta boîte que c'est une
c'est quand même une heure je sais pas
si aujourd'hui vous l'avez entendu mais
ça s'est réparti aussi en france
énormément et son petit réseau de femmes
qu'ils essayent de booster leur activité
et pour se faire connaître au ceva
connaît donc la fcc 50 exposants pour l
intérêt c'est de faire connaître en
activité voilà c'est déjà mettre en
avant donc le talent de la femme
reconnaît très leurs activités et
justement le fond qu'on va récolter
parce que l'entrée est payante
non pas du tout c'est gratuit alors on a
demandé jousson participation envisagée
dès 3 ans et a condamné que c'est le
premier salon des suçons versailles
on a donné l'accès à gratuit pour tous
les gens de la région des yvelines et on
demande de faire un don en fait tout ce
tout se suite tout est relié terre et
livre justement c'est celle là c'est
vivre ensemble c'est l'association fait
totalement absurde et l'ibook exactement
c'est annick bouquay sans parler à bas
ce serait très aimable surtout que je
tiens à faire un petit clin d'oeil à nyc
et reste un petit clin d'oeil à
pierrefonds se diront oui parce que
justement le 12 octobre il y à la dictée
pour tout ça oui
voilà et c'est l'argent qui en récolte
est pour cet événement ce sera ré versé
le 12 octobre au château de versailles
donc à tous ces milles enfants qui sont
dans des environnements défavorisés
malin corman pour la redistribuer ces
jeunes garçons bon lorenza malaise
baronne bravo balles en caoutchouc des
poufs est pas que ça donne forme aux
noirs cette belle association plaisir et
puis surtout l'espace a donné envie à
d'autres je sais pas ce que ma main et
au visage de près d'adhérer de vous
rejoindre pour cette belle cause
et on vous donne rendez vous samedi avec
ça on pourra voir à la rentrée et on va
suivre toutes vos actions vous est
réservé lorenza merci beaucoup
[Musique]